[Music]
on the second day in Korea I decided to
visit the historic nori and on fish
market and I brought my Korean teacher
Jin she'll with me what is what kind of
fish is that onion sa all be bow very
deeply does that mean they think I'm old
yeah but I'm not that old I'm be young
look at me
look this is seem like it does this seem
like how are you were you from Hong Kong
Kong yes are they about to commit a bank
robbery what's going on here what is
this cannon space fake boom is like male
fountain they're like God where my god
it's a fake penis yeah here's a guy that
loves his work and people often eat that
they like to eat that yeah I can touch
it if you want yeah oh I know I don't
need to come here one of these since
summer camp
no not good not good
chimera thank you for letting me hold
the the penises
apparently this fish market is also a
motorcycle race course maybe you could
give you some tips on how to better
connect with Korean people make a good
connection so none FIO know what's known
me i beautiful eyes yeah noon up i own
what did i do wrong there newton fi oh
yeah yeah and very beautiful smile miso
miso miso yep i oh we so hype fail look
at that how does one eat this you can it
raw some people it just full thing into
the mouth yeah doesn't it then take over
your body like an alien that makes us
back to the summit I'm gonna buy this as
a pet no pet no pet what surfaces she
doesn't care what I do with it this is
going to be my pet and he's going to
live with me and my family
hey his name is Samuel
[Applause]
unfortunately I was unable to bring
Samuel back to California with me
without breaking a number of foreign
state local laws so I took Samuel here
to the COEX aquarium these guys by the
way are all natural predators they can't
wait for him to come out and play
thank you so much for taking care of my
octopus female female my fish market
that people just eat regularly and
brought it here at an aquarium where
thousands and thousands of dollars will
be spent to care for it this is Lennon
O'Brien saying I've ruined another
country
you